大家好,我是山东大学网络空间安全学院唐鹏。
我将和大家分享数据要素可信流通技术目科第一讲,
插费隐私基础理论以核心概念。
该讲主要包括以下参规内容,
传统另一名技术中心化插费隐私和本地插费隐私。
在讨论隐私保护技术之前,
我们先了解一下隐私泄漏问题。
我们知道,数据共享往往会导致隐私泄漏。
像下面这个例子,
现在有一组医疗数据,
假设某机构要发布这组医疗数据,
与方面研究者进行医疗分析,
为了防止直接暴露患者的性命信息造成隐私泄漏。
在发布数据前,可以将患者性命信息隐藏。
但是,与这组各体相关的公开外部数据,
例如投标系统的注册信息,
可能包含性命信息,
进一步发现,
这组公开的注册信息,
从IS的邮编、年龄、性别三个属性的取职,
和发布的医疗数据中,
某一条纪录的邮编、年龄、性别三个属性取职完全相同,
而且与这条纪录在这三个属性取职相同的纪录,
只有这么一条。
那这样,攻击者可以断定IS就对应当前这条纪录。
那进一步可以推断IS患有软钞i,
从而导致IS个人隐私泄漏。
以上这种攻击,被称为外部链接攻击,
为了防止外部链接攻击,
可以采用匿名技术对数据进行脱敏处理,
概率技术将属性分成三类,
关键属性也称为准标志和敏感属性,
其中关键属性可以唯一识别一个个体,
例如姓名、声名证号、手机号码,
而准标志不能直接识别一个个体,
但是多个准标志组组合,
可以唯一识别大部分个体。
而敏感属性是研究人员所需要的。
那这样,在发布数据前,
为了防止隐私泄漏,
同时保证发布数据的可用性,
可以将关键属性进行隐藏,
对准标志组进行一定程度的泛化处理,
那敏感属性保持原样。
对匿名技术,
主要包括K匿名和对样性和T接近。
下面,我们简单介绍一下K匿名技术。
K匿名技术的目标是通过对准标志组进行泛化,
使得每个记录,
与至少K点一个其他记录,是不可区分的。
也就是说,
这K条记录,
它们在准标志组上的取值,
是完全相同的。
由这K个准标志组取着完全相同的记录,
组成一个等加类。
其中泛化是指,
用不太具体在予以一致的值,
替换准标志组。
例如,将数值属性具体的值泛化到某个区间,
将非类属性具体的类别泛化到更大的类别。
就像当前那一次,
一个年龄,
比如29,
227,具体的值泛化到20到30,
这样一个区间。
同时,
我们注意到K匿名,
它是对准标志组进行泛化处理,
在泛化过程当中,
并没有考虑敏感属性的取值。
下面是K匿名一个具体的例子,
我们利用K匿名技术,
将原始数据进行泛化处理,
假设我们将K帅成成2,
那这样,
就是原始数据被划分成多个等加类,
每个等加类至少包含两条记录。
这个时候,
如果攻击者利用外部链接攻击,
来进行切据隐私,
它至多可以断定,
某一个个体属于哪一个等加类,
但并不能确定,
这个攻击目标对应,
这个等加类当中哪一个个体,
从而有效防止隐私泄漏,
但是深入分析发现,
K匿名存在一定的隐私缺陷,
如果等加类当中,
敏感属性的取职,
缺乏多样性,
或者攻击者就有一定的背景知识,
那这样K匿名,
可能无法提供有效的隐私保护。
例如,
我们在进行K匿名处理的时候,
主要是对准标处进行泛化处理,
使得这个等加类当中,
准标处取职和完全相同,
那并没有考虑这敏感属性的取职,
那敏感属性可能取职不同,
也可能取职完全相同,
那如果敏感属性取职完全相同,
这个时候,
攻击者如果确定攻击目标属于这样一个等加类,
那即使不能确定这攻击目标对应哪一个个体,
但它依然能获取这个攻击目标,
它敏感属性的具体取职,
从而造成隐私泄漏,
这种攻击被称为一阵型攻击,
为了防止一阵型攻击,
可以对K匿名进行赶进。
那移出耳朵样性,
耳朵样性要求,
每个等加类当中,
敏感属性的职,
是必须得多样化的,
也就是说,
敏感属性的取职,
在一个等加类当中,
不能完全相同,
对于这个Io,
就是一个等加类当中,
敏感属性的取职不少于Io中,
但是进一步,
我们发现,
Io的耳朵性仍然存在一定的隐私泄漏,
如果我们在进行犯法处理的时候,
没有考虑敏感属性的语异,
或者敏感属性,
在原始数据库当中的总体分布,
比起在等加类当中的分布,
具有显著的这个不一致,
那这个时候耳朵样性,
可能仍然存在的一定的隐私泄漏,
例如,
在这样一个等加类当中,
某些属性,
它的敏感属性这个分布,
和在原始数据库当中的总体分布,
是在明显的差异,
那这个攻击者,
知道这个体属于这样一个等加类,
那它可以利用这种分布之间的差异,
来获取攻击目标,
它敏感属性去指一个信息,
这种攻击,
被称为偏斜性攻击,
为了防止偏斜性攻击,
可以对耳朵样性进一步感进,
提出,
替接近,
替接近要求,
每个等加类当中,
敏感属性,
它的分布,
应该接近,
它们在,
整个原始数据库当中的分布,
但我们发现,
你要求越高,
会导致,
犯法程度越大,
从而导致数据可用性降低,
以上,
这匿名技术,
我们可以认为,
是基于数据化分,
也就是说,
将某个具体的值,
犯法到某个区间,
将,
单个个体,
分到某个等加类,
也就是某一个字极,
而这类技术,
存在,
被攻击的风险,
被简单理解成,
从,
每个被犯法后的,
准标准角度来看,
一个个体,
它属于一个等加类,
也就是属于一个字极,
这个字极,
它包含多个个体,
那攻击者,
在进行外部链接攻击时,
它能知道,
这攻击目标,
属于哪一个字极,
但并不能确定,
对应哪一个个体,
但是对,
多个犯法后的准标而说,
一个个体,
可能同时属于,
多个字极,
这多字极,
可能仅包含,
一条记录,
那也就对应,
这个个体,
所谓导致隐私泄漏,
为此,
在2006年,
提出查分隐私技术,
该技术,
是基于,
数据扰动,
进行隐私保护,
所谓介绍查分隐私定义前,
我们先了解一个重要的概念,
相邻数据,
我们可以看一下,
下面有简单的例子,
现在有,
某个班级,
所有学生的成绩信息,
为了方便了解,
教学情况,
教育系统允许,
查询班级成绩的,
统计信息,
例如,
班里及格的人数,
平均分,
各个分数段,
人数分布,
等,
但不允许查询,
个体信息,
例如不能查询,
某个学生的,
具体成绩,
这时,
因为好奇的同学,
想知道,
小明考试,
是否及格,
假设这位好奇同学,
还知道小明之外,
其他同学的,
及格情况,
也就是说,
除小明之外,
班里及格的人数,
他知道的,
我们把,
除小明之外,
班里及格人数,
继承一。
这样假课,
是认为,
这位好奇同学,
具备最多的背景支持,
也就是,
具有最强的,
攻击能力,
那这个时候,
这个同学,
在,
攻击小明的,
整个成绩之前,
可以做出,
两种不同的假课,
假设一,
小明考试,
未及格,
假设二,
小明考试及格,
也就是,
针对小明,
考试结果,
两种不同的情况,
做出两种不同的假课,
这两个假课,
对应两个书记期,
这两个书记期,
就相差一条记录,
也就是说,
除了小明的考试,
结果不一样以外,
其他,
其所有同学的,
考试结果,
是相同的,
我们把这样,
仅相差一条记录的,
两个书记期,
成为相铃书记期,
那接着,
这位同学,
可以统计,
把你及格的人数,
把它记成B,
然后观察,
A和B是否相等,
如果A和B相等,
则第一种假课是成立的,
从而推断出,
小明考试,
未及格,
否则,
第二种假课成立的,
从而推断出,
小明考试及格,
通过这个例子,
我们发现,
这位好奇同学,
并没有直接,
访问小明的,
具体的成绩,
而是,
查询,
数据购物当中的,
统计信息,
有班里的及格的人数,
但是,
它可以通过,
这种统计信息,
来反推,
获取小明的,
及格情况,
可以造成小明,
各体隐私泄漏,
在攻击之前,
它根据,
小明考试结果,
两种不同的情况,
做出两种不同的假课,
因为,
它事先不知道,
它具体有没有考试及格,
所以,
它可以做出,
两种不同的假课,
然后,
根据这统计结果,
它可以判断,
哪一种假课,
是成立的,
那借儿,
可以确定,
小明这考试情况,
是什么样,
它上面这个例子,
我们发现,
就是,
精确的统计结果,
会造成,
个人隐私泄漏,
这是因为,
精确统计结果,
与输入数据之间,
是一应设的,
那通过这种一应设,
那就可以利用,
统计结果,
判断,
它对应的是,
哪一种输入,
从而推特,
原来数据当中,
各体的隐私信息,
为了防止攻击者,
利用精确统计结果,
推特个体隐私,
我们可以考虑,
将精确统计结果,
转化成,
一个随机变量,
也就是将,
精确统计,
转化成,
随机统计,
对于这随机统计,
我们就是将,
统计结果,
不再,
是一个,
确定的值,
而是,
俯从,
某个分布的随机变量,
那一方面,
让得到精确统计结果,
或者是,
得到于,
精确统计结果,
差别较小的,
就结果,
概率足够大,
所以保证结果,
可用性,
或者可靠性。
另一方面,
对于任意种输出,
它来自两个,
相连数据级的,
概率差异,
足够小,
从而保证隐私,
也就是,
降低,
单条纪录,
对统计结果影响,
从而防止攻击者,
通过统结果,
推断单程纪录的敏感信息。
简单理解,
据说,
原先,
一个输入,
对应一个输出,
那这样,
根据输出,
就可以反推输入,
那对一个随意统计,
一个输入,
可以对应多个输出,
反过来,
一个输出,
可能来自多个输入,
而且,
这个,
输出,
它来自不同输入的,
是概率差异很小,
如果我们,
没有办法区分这种差异的话,
那就不能判断,
当前的这个输出,
究竟来自哪一个输入,
也就不能推断,
原数据当中,
各起的这个敏感信息,
那对于,
不同的这个输入,
它的输出结果,
俯仇不同的分布,
这两个分布之间的差异,
我们称为,
隐私损失,
或者隐私风险大小,
那很明显,
分布差异越大,
隐私风险越大,
分布差异越小,
隐私风险越小,
就说,
分布差异越大,
那工具者,
就越容易判断,
哪一种输入,
是合理的,
从而窃取隐私,
那分布差异,
可以用人意散度,
来进行度量,
人意散度,
它当中,
包含一个重要的参数,
二法,
当二法等于一的时候,
那人意散度,
就退化成,
KL散度,
当二法越大,
越关注,
分布差异,
脚大的区域,
当二法区域,
挣无穷的时候,
就度量分布,
差异之间的,
最大值,
那基于,
相邻数据级,
和隐私,
损失量化,
可以给出,
差异隐私的,
形式化定义,
也就是,
人意,
给定,
两个,
相邻数据级,
第和第一篇,
随即含述,
F,
如果满足,
差异隐私的话,
那当前紧当,
对人意,
输出,
O,
其在两个,
相邻数据级的,
条件概率,
差异,
足够小,
差异的上限,
我们用,
易的,
英文词能,
来表示,
易文词能,
被成为隐私预算,
其中,
易文词能越大,
表示,
数据用者,
能接受的,
隐私泄乐风险,
就越大,
实现,
差异隐私的,
机制,
有很多,
当,
统计含述的结果,
是一个,
实数,
或者是,
实数下量的时候,
我们可以,
利用,
拉普拉斯机制,
实现,
差异隐私,
也就是,
在精确的,
统计结果中,
加入,
变量,
该参数,
这个,
该变量,
是一种,
期望为零的,
对称分布,
而且,
随着,
随即变量的,
变大,
对应的,
概率,
指数级下降,
拉普拉斯分布,
有一个,
重要的参数,
拉曼达,
他决定了,
噪音规模,
拉曼达越大,
扰动后的结果,
就越不精确,
那么,
为了保证,
同结果的精确性,
我们希望,
拉曼达越小越好,
但拉曼达取值,
有一定的要求,
它是由,
隐私预算意味伺能,
和,
统计寒数的敏感度,
来决定的。
隐私预算,
我们前面,
已经介绍过,
那我们,
介绍一下,
寒数的敏感度,
寒数敏感度,
是指,
修改数据级,
当中的一条记录,
对统计,
寒数的输出结果,
最大影响,
例如,
当统计搬进,
及格的人数的时候,
统计结果,
是一个数值,
那修改一名同学的成绩,
这个数值变化,
最大是一,
说有一个同学,
参加了谷考,
从,
为及格变成及格,
那及格的人数,
就会加一,
我参加谷考,
没有及格,
那这样,
及格的人数,
没有任何变化,
那一个变化是一,
一个变化是零,
那最大变化是一,
那,
对另外一种,
就是统计操作,
比如统计,
各个分数段,
这个人数,
那这个时候,
修改一条记录,
对统计结果影响,
这个变化,
最大是二,
那具体怎么计算?
如果我们要统计,
各个分数段,
有及格的人数,
输出,
不再是,
一个数,
还是一个项量,
那项量,
包含多个元素,
那修改,
一个同学的成绩,
它可能,
会影响,
项量当中,
这个多个元素的,
这个值,
我们深入分析发现,
它至多影响,
其中两个元素值,
比如说,
本来从,
50到60这个分数段,
通过谷考,
变成了,
就是,
去10到80,
这个分数段,
那这样,
每个元素,
最大变化量,
这一,
两个元素,
整体的变化量,
就是二,
所以,
对于这种统计,
还说,
敏感度是二,
那,
敏感度越大,
表示修改,
一条记录,
对于统计结果的影响,
就越大,
从而需要引入,
更多的噪音,
它抵消这种影响,
以防止这个隐私陷入,
也就是说,
在隐私,
预算一定的情况下,
敏感度越大,
噪音规模就越大,
同时,
我们可以通过,
下面这个式子,
来证明,
拉帕拉斯机制,
还可以满足,
这个查比尔斯,
这个定义要求,
那具体我们看一下,
就是,
当,
这个输出,
是这个外的时候,
那我们可以计算,
来自两个,
这个D和D一片,
它们发生的这个概率,
之间的这个差异,
那我们把这种概率,
转化成,
拉帕拉斯分布,
上的这个概率,
具体怎么转化,
因为当前的输出是外,
那如果,
D一片,
它的精确统结果是H一片,
那加入的噪音量,
就是外-H一片,
那如果D,
它精确输出H,
那加入的噪音,
就是外-H,
那这个时候,
两个概率,
实际上是分别对应,
生存的这个噪音,
是外-H一片的概率,
和外-H这个概率,
然后我们计算,
这两个概率之间的差异,
可以得到,
就是它们小E等于E的,
拉帕拉斯分支,
H-H一片绝对值,
这次方,
让H-H一片,
可以认为,
是,
两个随机辩量,
它们输出这个差异,
我们知道输出差异最大值,
是要小E等于D,
也就是小E等于敏感度,
然后D出于蓝帽它,
实际上就等于E,
这个去值,
那既然我们可以得到,
这两个概率之间的差异,
实际上是小E等于E的E,
既然证明,
拉帕拉斯机制,
可以满足差异因斯,
这包括要求,
当统计结果,
是从一个集合当中,
选取一个或多个元素,
那这个时候,
我们不能再用拉帕拉斯机制,
在输出结果当中,
加入一定的这个噪音,
这样是没有什么意义的,
那我们可以,
利用指数机制,
来实现差异因斯,
也就是将一个精确的选择,
变成一个随机的选择,
例如,
我们从所有课程当中,
选取最受欢迎的课程,
那一种方式,
是大家进行投票,
然后得票最多的,
然后就认为是最受欢迎的,
那这个时候,
可能会造成一定的隐私泄漏,
那为了防止隐私泄漏,
我们可以制定一个评为函数,
也就是美媒课程,
它得到的票数,
认为是对它的一个打分,
然后我们不再直接选取,
打分最高的那一名课程,
而是打分高的这个课程,
被选取的概率更大,
这样就把一个精致的选择,
变成一个随机选择,
通过引入这样一定的随机性,
来保护这各起的隐私信息,
在实际应用当中,
往统计课程是比较复杂的,
对包含一系列的统计函数,
这个时候,
我们利用差分隐私组合性质,
来度量整体的隐私强度,
那组合性质,
要包括串营组合和病情组合,
其中串营组合性质是指,
应用在同一组数据及地上的M个算法,
A1,A2,一直到AM,
如果他们分别满足Evenson i差分隐私,
这他们整体就满足Evenson 1,
加Evenson 2,一直加到Evenson m差分隐私,
这个我们可以理解成,
如果在同一组数据上,
不断地进行访问,
那每一次访问数据,
就会造成一定的隐私泄漏风险,
那这个隐私泄漏风险,
是会累加,
而另一种组合性质,
是串营,是病情组合性质,
它是指,将数据及地,
按照记录,
划分成多个互互相交的字极,
第一,第二,一直到第M,
其中用M个算法,
分别作用于第一,第二到第M,
这M个不同字极,
皆分别满足Evenson i差分隐私,
这对于整个数据级来说,
它是满足Evenson i最大质的差分隐私,
也就是说,整个数据级的隐私泄漏风险,
是由这M个字极,
隐私泄漏风险最大的来决定的,
那对于这个病情组合性质,
我们说,它可以通过有效的对数据级划分,
来降低这个隐私预算消耗,
但是我们需要注意,
这个病情组合性质,
它是按照记录,
来对数据级进行这个划分,
怎么理解,按照记录,
对数据级进行划分,
我们可以想象这样一个简单的例子,
如果我们对班级这个成绩信息进行多次查询,
第一次统计90分以上的这个人数,
然后第二次统计80到90,
然后第三次统计80分以下的,
那这个时候我们发现,
这三次统计,
它们是对应的不同的这个词期,
那我们可以把整个数据当中所有的记录,
分成三不同的词期,
然后大于90的看那个词期,
然后八岁以下的看那个词期,
它区域的看那个词期,
然后三次统计分别作用在三不同的词期,
那我们说,
因为每次统计是作用在不同词期,
它不存在隐私,
卸了空显的这个累加,
那我们就可以利用这个穿,
这个病情组合性质,
来量化整体的这个隐私预算,
或者隐私卸了空显的大小,
但是,
如果我们说,
当前的班尼学生这个成绩信息,
一共放下三名课程成绩,
然后语文,数学,英语,
分为继承A,B,C,
然后第一次我们要统计,
就语文这名课程,
这个,平均成绩,
然后第二次统计,
数学这名课程,平均成绩,
第三次统计,
英语这名课,平均成绩,
那我们,
简单理解,
就可以看成,
对数级第一次统计,
所数级当中的第一列,
然后第二次看的第二列,
第三次统计第三列,
那这个时候,
你可以利用,
病情组合性质,
来量化整体的影碎的风险,
而答案是不行的,
为什么?
就是因为,
这个病情组合性质,
它是,
要求按照记录,
划分不同的字机,
而,
现在这种,
是按照,
这个,
属性,
划分不同的,
这个字机,
那为什么,
按照属性划分不同的字机,
就不满足,
病情组合性质,
根据差分隐私定义,
我们是,
防止,
攻击者,
利用这个统计结果,
推断,
个体的,
这个隐私信息,
那我们,
需要从个体的角度,
来考虑问题,
那对于,
前面,
这个例子,
你三次查询,
第一次查询就是位上,
见询查询80到90,
见询查询,
那对于一个个体来说,
它只会,
属于,
某一个字机,
那,
只会影响,
其中一次查询,
也就是,
在某一次查询的时候,
可能,
会导致,
这个体的隐私泄漏,
那我们可以,
利用这个,
病情组合性,
但是对于,
第二种情况,
我们的统计语文证明课,
评计成绩的时候,
会,
牵涉到,
当前这个个体,
它的这个,
语文这个成绩信息,
然后在统计数学证明课,
评计成绩的时候,
会牵涉到,
这个个体,
它数学证明课,
就成绩,
当统计英语,
评计成绩的时候,
会牵涉到,
这个个体,
英语,
它的这个成绩,
也就是,
三次查询,
都会牵涉到这个个体,
那也就是说,
每一次统计,
这个个体,
都存在,
一定的隐私泄漏风险,
那,
三次统计,
在隐私泄漏风险,
只要累加起来的,
那这个时候,
也就解释了,
为什么电动情况,
我们不能利用,
病情组合性质,
来量化整体的,
隐私泄漏风险,
以上查询隐私中,
存在一个,
统一的数据管理者,
就是所有个体,
他们相信,
这个统一的数据管理者,
并将数据,
交给这个数据管理者,
进统一保管,
那这个时候,
当有数据管理者,
发送查询请求,
那数据管理者,
会享用查询请求,
去保卫整个数据库,
并在精确统计结果上,
加入一份噪音,
将还有噪音结果,
保管给数据分析者,
也就是说,
有数据管理者,
来保护,
数据当中,
个体的美感信息,
当然,
在很多场景下,
并不存在这样一个,
可信的数据管理者。
比如,
我们手机用户,
他们更愿意将,
自己的通话记录,
照片等数据,
就自己保管,
而不愿意,
直接交给,
手机服务提供商,
那这个时候,
就需要用到,
本地查询师,
那我们看一下,
集中查询师,
和本地查询师,
两个的区别,
主要就在于,
有没有一个,
可信的数据管理者,
如果存在一个,
那就有,
这个管理者,
来统一管理数据,
然后,
那就有,
这个统计的,
数据管理者,
来保护,
用户的隐私,
那如果,
不存在一个,
可信的这第三方,
那就要有,
用户自身,
来保管自己的数据,
那就进一步,
就是要求,
用户自己,
来保证,
自己的数据隐私,
要本地查询师,
可以用,
本地查询师协议,
来对数据,
进行本地扰动,
那本地查询师协议,
基本了成,
包括以下四部,
编码,
扰动,
聚合,
估计,
就是编码,
是由每个用户,
在本地执行,
要接受一个,
输入值,
用输出,
一个编码值,
而扰动,
也是由,
每个用户执行,
将编码值,
经扰动,
并输出,
聚合,
是由聚合器,
或者是,
数据收集者,
来执行,
要接受,
所有报告的值,
并输出,
聚合信息,
而估计,
也是由聚合器执行,
根据聚合信息,
利用参入,
估计的方法,
估计,
原始数据的,
统计信息,
下面介绍,
几种典型的,
本地差别隐私协议,
首先,
是随机响应机制,
当用户数据,
为二支属性的时候,
也就是,
取出空间,
为零,
合一,
两种取值,
可以采用,
随机响应机制,
进行隐私保护,
为可以看,
简单理解成,
就是,
抛硬币,
该协议,
在数据扰动时,
以P的概率,
保持不变,
以KU的概率反转,
其中,
一家KU是等于,
P比上KU,
等于E的意味性的方式,
例如,
某个用户,
原数据值等于E,
那它又以P的概率,
上传E,
或者是KU的概率,
上传零,
由此可以看出,
该协议,
它是具有对称性,
也就是,
不管零,
和E,
都是进行相同的方式,
进行扰动,
接着,
聚合器统计,
扰动后,
零或E的个数,
分别,
利用下面的公式,
来估计,
原始数据当中,
零或E的,
这个个数,
这就是,
随机响应机制,
为本地查备影子协议,
我们需要分析去,
正确性,
隐私性和效用,
为随机响应机制的,
正确性,
为可以通过证明,
去估计职,
就无偏性来说明,
具体过程如下,
假设,
在所有N个用户中,
真实是唯一的比例为π,
现已π作为参数,
我们进行统计,
可以得到,
每个用户,
扰动值等于E的这个概率,
和扰动值等于零的概率,
接着,
根据观测到的,
扰动后E的个数,
和零的个数,
来构建四转函数,
对于四转函数,
取对数,
就得到这个对数四转函数,
接着,
对对数四转函数,
进行求到,
并容导数等于零,
被计算得到这个π的,
最大四转估计值,
计算这个最大四转估计值,
它的期望,
我们可以得到,
这个估计值期望,
是等于这个π的,
从而可以得到,
这个估计值,
是真实的π的,
无偏估计,
进一步,
我们根据这个π,
与这个一个个数,
和之间的关系,
可以得到,
这个个数的估计值,
是真实的个数的,
无偏估计,
从而保证,
随即响应机制的,
证确性,
对于其隐私性,
我们可以根据,
查问隐私的定义,
来进行证明,
因为,
因为任意种输出,
比如说,
输出为一,
它可能来自于,
一,
也可能来自零,
然后,
如果来自一的话,
它相当于保持不变,
这种情况,
那发生的概率,
就说是,
这个π,
如果来自于是零,
那相当于,
有一个反转,
那发生的概率是q,
因为我们开始要求,
π比上q,
只要小1等于1,
因此,
那所以,
对输出为一的时候,
它是满足查问隐私的要求,
或者满足本地查问隐私的要求,
那由于对称性,
那输出是零,
也满足本地查问隐私的要求,
所以说,
隐私想要机制,
它的隐私性,
是没有问题,
那对于这个数据效用,
我们是通过,
估计结果,
它的这个方差,
来进行量化,
对于隐私想要机制,
它计算出来方差,
就是下面这个式子,
那如果,
用户的数据,
不再是2只属性,
而是多只属性的时候,
即,
取之空间,
为从一到地,
地中取之,
那这个时候,
我们对隐私想机制,
进行推广,
也被称为,
广义隐私想机制,
也利用广义隐私想机制,
进行隐私保护,
那广义隐私想机制,
它的协议流程,
和隐私想要机制,
基本相同,
主要区别就在于,
我们在扰动的时候,
由于原先,
只有两种取之,
它对应的输出,
这个取之空间,
也是两种,
而广义隐私想机制当中,
输出,
只有地中不同的句子,
那我们把保处不变的概率,
集成p,
扰动成其他值的概率,
集成q,
那,
现在是p,
加上,
地减1倍的q,
等于,
同时,
我们要求,
p比上q,
是小1等于1的e means,
也就是,
保证,
它满足,
本地差别也是要求,
那接着,
继于扰动结果,
然后聚合器,
进行聚合,
和估计,
那,
最后我们可以计算,
就是广义隐私想用机制,
它估计值,
的方差,
来量化,
叫数据效用,
通过方差,
我们可以看出来,
对广义隐私想用机制,
估计是方差,
与地,
成线性相关,
随着地越大,
它方差就越大,
那这个时候,
就说明,
当,
数据取得空间,
较大的时候,
我们用广义隐私想用机制,
会导致数据效用,
小差,
当用户数据为多值属性时,
我们也可以采用,
优异机制,
来进行隐私保护,
与广义隐私想用机制,
有所不同,
我们具体看一下,
它的协议流程,
首先,
编码,
优异机制,
将真实职位,
编码成,
长度为地的,
零下量,
我们集成B,
在B中,
第V位为1,
其一位为0,
例如用户提交的数据,
为优,良,差,
在对应的数值,
为123,
对取得空间大小,
等于3,
在编码之后的,
相量长度,
也为3,
在1,
被编码成100,
就是第1位的1,
去2位得0,
然后2,
被编码成010,
3,
被编码成001,
接着,
对编码之后的,
相量进行扰动,
也就是,
按照下表,
所示的,
转移概率,
对编码之后的,
相量B,
每一位进行扰动,
例如,
U,
对应的,
转移,
编码之后的概率,
是100,
就是第1位,
是1,
去2位是0,
在扰动的过程当中,
让第1位,
以P的概率保持为1,
1.P的概率,
反转成0,
然后,
第2,3位,
非没有Q的概率,
反转成1,
1.Q的概率,
保持0,
最后,
扰动过的相量,
这个B1,
可能变为001,
那也有可能,
扰动过程当中,
每一位都发生了反转,
就扰动之后的相量,
为011,
也可能,
每一位都保持不变,
就扰动之后的相量,
为100,
接着聚合器,
根据用户,
提交的扰动之后的相量,
进行聚合和估计,
例如,
它要估计,
这是值为i的个数,
那它就统计,
扰动之后的相量,
中,
第1位为1的,
就是相量的个数,
假设为ci,
那接着利用ci,
计算,
这个i个数的一个估计值,
ci-nq,
处于p-q,
例如,
要统计u的这个个数,
用户发送的相量,
是100,
010,
001,
101,
在这5个,
扰动之后的相量当中,
其中有3个相量,
第1位是等于1,
要这样,
1,
它的估计值,
就是3-5位的q,
处于p-q,
这里我们注意到,
在估计的时候,
和估计值公式,
和随机想机制,
或者是广义随机想机制,
是一致的,
但是随机想机制,
和广义随机想机制,
比较直观,
那我们这里就简单解释一下,
这个式子,
它这个含义,
或者说这个公式的由来,
我们知道,
对于真实用户取值为i,
那编码之后的相量,
第2位是等于1,
然后其1位,
g等于0,
那我们根据这样一个,
把原始的这个,
真实用户,
分成两组,
第1组,
就是它们真实取值等于i,
然后第2组,
真实取值,
不等于i,
那对于第1组用户,
它编之后的相量,
第2位是等于1,
而对于第2组用户,
编码之后的限量,
第2位是等于0,
我们暂时不管,
它哪一位是等于1,
我们现在主要的关心,
第2位就取值,
接着,
它们在上传数据之前已经扰纵,
对于第1组用户,
它们是以p的概率,
保持不变,
就是1,
整然为1,
然后1-p的概率,
就反转成0,
而对第2组用户,
它真实取值,
是0,
然后它以这个q的概率,
反转成1,
然后1-q的概率,
保持不变,
那对于这个聚合器来说,
它观测到第2位,
唯一的这个用户个说,
就是着动之后的限量当中,
第2位等于1,
这个限量的个说是ci,
这是一个观测值,
那第2位等于1的这些限量,
它们可能来自两种情况,
第一种情况,
就是,
原来第2位本身为1,
在扰动的过程当中,保持不变,
整然为1,
第二种情况,就是,
扰动之后,
扰动之后限量为1,
但扰动之前的,
限量值,
第2位是等于0,
那这样,就是有0,
反转成1,
那对应的概率是q,
对于第1种情况,
它其实是对应第1组用户,
也就是,
真实是本身是i的,
那我们把这组用户,
是个说继承Ni,
然后第2种情况,
是对应第2组用户,
它们真实是不等于1,
我们把这个个说继承Ni,
那这样,
就是有第1组用户,
然后提交第2位在1,
这些限量的个数,
这个期望值,
得等于Ni,
扰成1p,
然后第2组用户,
它提交之后,
提交的扰动之后的限量,
那第2位等于1,
这样限量的个数,
这个期望值,
是N-Ni,
扰成1q,
那所有的用户,
它们提交的扰动之后的限量,
第2位等于1的个数,
它的期望值,
就是Ni-Np,
加Ni-Nq,
这是第2位,
等于1,
对限量个数,
一个期望值,
而聚合器观测到的,
这个值为Ci,
在随机想机制,
或者广一随机想机制,
我们在证明,
它协议证据性的时候,
已经推倒出,
一个变量,
它的期望值,
要近似等于,
它的这个观测值,
那这个时候,
就是第2位,
等于它这个,
期望值和观测值,
我们已经计算出来,
然后我们让,
两端就是相等,
或者是近似相等,
就得到这样一个式子,
求解这个式子,
我们就能推倒出下面,
一个式子,
就得到,就是,
这次值为i的用户,
它课数的一个近似值,
或者说估计值,
这是这个式子,
它的这个优兰,
对于优异级值,
为了满足Evenson,
我们本地查证诗,
让我们参数,
需要满足条件1,
P 倍的1.q,
比让K 倍的1.p,
要小一点1.Evenson,
如果,
要求它像,
广义随即小硬计之一样,
满足对称性,
也就满足条件2,
P 加Q 是等于1,
这时,
估计值的方差,
就等于,
N 乘E,
E 的2分这Evenson 次方,
除E,
减1,泡到平方,
事实上,
我们发现,
条件2不是必须的,
我们在满足E的条件下,
可以计算,
更加合理的,
扰动参数,
使得方差更小,
这时,
就优异方案,
它只有一个变量Q,
我们可以对齐,
求偏倒,
零零倒数等于0,
计算得到,
P 等于2分之1,
Q 等于E 的Evenson 加1,
分之1,
这是计算出来的方差,
等于N 乘以4倍的
E 的Evenson 次方,
除E 的Evenson 次方,
减1,泡到平方,
我们发现,
方差明显降低,
而且,
这方差E取得空间第无关,
此外,
我们介绍一种,
由谷歌开发的一种
隐私保护技术,
用于收集用户的
统计数据,
还不暴露个人身份
或敏感信息,
这种技术被称为
Bravo 机制,
它是使用
哈希函数和随计化的组合
来保护用户的隐私。
这协议流程如下,
首先,
每个用户借助
布伦过滤器,
将一个输入域
为D 的
值位编码程,
一个D 为的
二进制项量,
B0,
用户有M 和
哈希函数H1H2
HM,
每个哈希函数
它输出就满足,
这个HV
属于0-K-1
这个区间,
然后用户分别计算,
这个V 在哈希函数
H1H2
一直到HM 下的
M 和哈希值,
并令B0
中对应的
这些位置为1,
第一位为0,
得到编码,
这个项量B0,
接着对编码中的项量B0,
进入扰动,
这扰动,
它分两步进行,
第一步,
是永久性随机响应,
即对B0的每一位
进行随机响应,
得到B1,
永久随机响应,
对每一个数据,
只执行一次,
第二步,
会顺时随机响应,
对B1中每一位
再进行随机响应,
该步骤,
在每次收集各数据时,
都会执行,
扰动之后,
得到项量B2,
这两步都满足对阵性,
也就是说,
对于0或1,
它没扰动的,
这个概率是一致的,
那这样就要求,
在这个随机响应的时候,
要保证P加Q是等于1,
这样,
每位无论是0或1,
保留真实值的概率,
均是相同的,
最后是聚合,
在数据收集者,
收集所有用户,
扰动数据后,
它估计原始数据平数,
其中,
在Rubber机制当中,
聚合算法,
交为复杂,
再使用拉锁回归,
或者现已回归,
进行这个平数估计,
以上是这一讲的主要内容,
欢迎大家随时讨论!